in eight years of fighting in eastern
ukraine the front lines did not change
much
now in less than two weeks separatist
fighters from donetsk and lugansk with
russian support are making significant
inroads into ukrainian-held territory
but it seems it's not been easy
there is too many opponents constant
fears fighting we are under constant
pressure i can't say we have suffered a
lot of casualties but our guys are under
fire all the time
when we came here we thought there
wouldn't be much resistance
burgas is one of a dozen towns and
villages the lugansk and donetsk forces
say they've seized so far
the people here say they've had no
electricity heat or water for 10 days
they've only emerged from their bomb
shelters for the food handed out by the
donetsk authorities
can you give me some flowers this woman
asks
[Music]
with so many more women in the basement
she says
this village is along the humanitarian
corridor that was supposed to allow
people to leave the city of von navaja
which is surrounded by forces from
russia and donetsk
the front line has moved about sort of a
few kilometers
uh to my left towards volnervacher but
it remains
a very dynamic
environment there is still the constant
sound
of shelling so although they're supposed
to be a ceasefire there is still
uh firing going on and it's going to be
an enormous challenge for the people who
want to leave vulnerable
to make it here certainly along the road
we came in on there was still clearly an
active battlefield grad rockets landed
just a few meters from our convoy as we
headed to burgas
the people here have been living with
conflict like this for eight years
peace peace peace we only want peace
these women say
the don yes military says here it's
mainly fighting what it calls ukrainian
nationalists that's a russian
description for paramilitaries it wants
to distinguish from the regular
ukrainian army
you can see how they follow the
ceasefire here the head of the local
administration tells me
ten days ago the forces from donetsk and
lugansk recognized as republics by
russia controlled only a third of the
territory considered part of their
donbass region they looked to have
clawed back a lot more since then
bernard smith al-jazeera donbass